That's like uh like Destiny might have just shaken up this family
a little bit. Okay, it's possible. >> Oh my god, what the
is this? >> Hassan is like God's most blessed >> Okay.
Okay. The snook mentality is getting out of control on the JTO
stream. Okay. He does not have child. All right. Google has child.
>> He's just got the login. >> Han is like literally
he did nothing. He's just done nothing. He just sits back and
like these two the two people who've been like trying to destroy
his life for the past 2 years just turned against each other
and now they're just trying to kill each other and Assan's sitting
back like looking around. He didn't do Han Hassan just shows
up and he he gets to win like God just decided he was blessed.
>> You're like trying to tell me that you have child. Why
are you trying to tell me that you have child? Like like almost
unlucky. Okay, I was going to see this as well. Did Lunar Box
get to any of the Ethan video before he watched the Destiny response?
This is all Destiny response. Seems like he was watching a little
bit of Ethan here before. >> A lot of people start hitting
puberty at 12 and did nothing with it. If you think that's cool,
>> you have no idea what I've done with anything. Okay,
I've retained multiple offers related to this case. Number one.
Number two, I do not any of this >> Hold on. Hold on. That's
incredibly important. Load box, please. Load box, please. Load
box, please. that he just said something really important.
Dickers, Dickers, did you react to this?
Did you react to this? Because I I think I I listened and I I
thought it was really funny how he cooked Ethan Klein. Okay,
I did think that was funny. But it's very interesting. There's
a couple different points where what he says and how specific
he is kind of gives the game away. Mostly, okay, it's when he
says, "I've retained none of this stuff on my computer. I don't
have any
on my computer." Right. the the continual the continual qualifier
of on my computer is like the most obvious. It's for some reason
you're telling us explicitly you're still retaining this this
CC, right? Like you're making it very obvious that you are still
retaining it in your possession somehow.
Hello, >> dude. I spotted the exact same thing. I know
what you're talking about. Yeah, I mean Destiny does this all
the time, right? I pointed this out when I went over it live.
Like Destiny won't usually lie. He'll just kind of sell you a
narrative and talk about all the facts that maybe push you there,
but he'll never explicitly say it, dude. And he literally emphasizes
it at some points. He's like, "Well, I've got none of this stuff.
None of this is like a legend seam or like none of this is like
on my computer." It's like what? >> There's one point where
he does the most awkward timing ever. He's like, "I've never
had any of this kind of material, the child beast material >> on
my computer." Like he actually has a pause there that makes it
so comedic that I'm like actually almost in tears laughing at
him. >> It's like dude, you are you're like trying to tell
me that you have child. Why are you trying to tell me that you
have child? Like almost explicitly.
>> Okay. Okay. The snock mentality is getting out of control
on the JTO stream. Okay. He does not have child. All right. Google
has child. >> He's just got the login.
>> Just to be clear. Okay. Just to be super duper clear,
>> dude. like or it's like on an encrypted hard drive or
it's like like there's something like this where
like maybe there's some play they're trying to do. I can't I
can't I don't even know where he like saved all of this and put
it on an encrypted hard drive and put it in like a safety deposit
box for his lawyers like letting them access or something. And
but but it's still retention, right? It's still retention no
matter how much you've you >> immediate access to it though.
He's got enough access that clearly I mean he says in the DMs
with him back it's like it's not even like a really like an inference.
He says that he's been looking over the stuff again, right? To
be able to like Whoa, I never realized this was all filmed on
Skype. He's been looking over it again. So he's clearly got enough
access to be able to like randomly peruse. No. >> Um so
I I think what he's looking over is that group chat. That's what
I think. I think he's grabbing pictures from that group chat
that he sent to them. I think he's sending that stuff along.
That's that's my read, but I I can't say for sure. I don't think
he's looking at that material explicitly. I think he's looking
at the group chat logs and looking at like the pictures he'd
sent there. And I'm guessing this is the one thing where I wish
I had any kind of bridge with Willy Mack cuz I I I hypothesized
this immediately. When he posts that screenshot of VC,
I think he would have posted a link to another file that would
have been in from that group chat. I bet you if you were to match
that channel ID up with a channel ID from um from the Rose Leaks
from his Rose Leaks in May, I bet you that channel ID matches.
That's that's my >> that's my hypothesis.
I can't ask Willie that directly. But >> that would only
work though if Destiny had copied the link for the Discord asset
rather than actually like copying the image though, right? Maybe
because I would guess that Discord's got some stuff in there
to save space on their end where if people are copying files
between things and it recognizes like a hash or something. It
just like goes and says, "Oh, you have access." Yeah. Blah blah
blah. It does like a translation depending on how you copy paste
it, right? That would be very easy to code into something. Uh
we'll have to see. Yeah, we'll have to >> Somebody should
send a message. That'd be interesting. Yeah. What I wanted to
ask you. Okay. I want to ask you about Loner Box. What is going
on with this guy? Huh? Just like out of nowhere, his only commentary
is like repeating Destiny's talking points. >> I I thought
that he was like vaguely like distancing from Destiny.
>> So, I think he's
somewhat distanced. I think he
uh how could I put it? I think he's probably not so dissimilar
from Willy Mack in that he probably has followed Destiny for
a long time. He probably thinks Destiny's like correct on a lot
of things. and he doesn't want to like push away Desessie's audience.
I don't think he wants to he doesn't want to overreact to his
like repulsion to Destiny and push away like some of the people
who like the same political points, but I think I think there's
too much charity being granted to Destiny's point of view and
some of the things he's saying.
>> Uh that's that's like my read.
Cuz another thing that I wanted to ask you is like other than
other than just Destiny using the word even food shops isn't
using the uh the trafficker label. Like is there any evidence
for this or is this just like Destiny saying it? Like is there
any evidence that like Solo was like pimping her out or involved
in any way with Rose's like Twitter operation or whatever the
[__] other than he was having sex with her or her
boyfriend at the time was having sex with her and then they were
recording that. Well, hold on. Cuz do you remember that whole
chart that Loner Box was drawing with all of these circles? And
he's like, well, he's not going to admit to the pixie thing because
there's all these insane
accusations that clearly are not true. I genuinely think that
Loner Box doesn't believe any of them.
>> Oh, possibly. >> And it doesn't believe any of
what Destiny's saying. doesn't believe any of um the accusations
against Destiny outside of like the Pixie stuff that like it's
possible he um he basically downplays quite a bit of the stuff
that wasn't explicitly in the Pixie
um and that like anything from Kiwi Farms he's looking at is
possibly fake. >> Huh. I I understand the skepticism. Um
but like >> Oh man.
>> two things look into it. >> Yeah. Do you want
to say sorry you were you were going in a direction there. I'm
like trying to think um Oh, I had some answer to your question.
Can you can you lay out your question one more? >> Oh.
Oh, I was asking about the uh the trafficking angle. Is that
literally just what Destiny >> says even Yeah, that is
literally what Destiny says. So, it might be that he thinks Destiny
has some underlying knowledge there. Or it could also be that
um Oh, what is it that there's just some some there's some stuff
in the logs where I think Destiny Destiny had said to me that
I think that there were videos of her other guys. I think that
he said that either to me or Solo. He said it somewhere right
in those logs like way before. I think he said to me that that
this guy was like a and let her other guys. I want to say that's
like somewhere in my logs with him. So like I think there's some
idea that she had videotapes and Destiny suggests with Willie
Mac I think in the logs with Willy Mack that there was like a
hotel, right? That that's what they're trying to pinpoint or
is that in the in the stream where he talks about that screenshot.
He talks about how she was in a hotel some random dude. So it
seems like there's some concept of them going to a hotel and
a different guy shows up to have sex with her. So that's where
I think the trafficking concept comes >> But that's just
like
listen, I this isn't my world. But is that not quite is that
not relatively common for people who like like pimp out their
wives? Well, pimp out their wives like do hot wifeing or whatever
the [__] >> It might be. I don't know what
their ages were. And like it could be a fetish. It could be like
not trafficking. It could be something they participated in equally.
Like trafficking would be like against her will, right? >> Maybe.
Or maybe if she's under 18 and he's over 18, then even if it's
a consensual thing, it's still
>> Would it be? I mean, dude, we did the Destiny did the
entire Andrew Tate arc where he like nails down his definition
of trafficking and what trafficking means. And now it comes down
to they're within a Romeo and Juliet and they do like stuff.
That's trafficking. Like by any any ordinary definition of the
word, that's not trafficking. That's not human trafficking or
trafficking of a minor. >> Yeah. But I I mean if it's somebody
who's 18, who's an adult, who's a legal adult, who is participating
in this person prostituting themselves and recording stuff and
selling the materials they record, I like I I don't know how
a court defines that. I actually don't know for sure. That one's
>> I would say there's proof of it, though. >> It
might be weird, right? It might be participating in the production
of child. You might be able to say that 100%. trafficking.
>> Where was Solo getting any of the money
>> Like he's not getting none of the money flow goes from
Rose to Solo. We've got no evidence for that, >> I think.
So, is there not a cash app that was in his name? Was that ever
on any of Rose's socials? I actually don't >> Um, not so
far as I know. A cash app. >> There's there's some cash
app stuff here that goes on that like
I there's some idea that his name was like uh George something,
right? And that goes to like an identity from a cash app, I think.
But that's really like getting deep into stuff that people have
looked into and I I'm like not a 100% sure on. So I probably
shouldn't speak on it until I'm 100% up. >> Okay. Maybe
the stuff that for me to to look into. Fair play. Fair play.
>> But I'm I'm I'm thinking about it and the the other
like the fact of the matter is while I think it's the most likely
hypothesis, I think it's like a 95% chance that this is her boyfriend,
somebody she knows in real life, there isn't conclusive proof.
Like there is far more conclusive proof that she's a minor than
any conclusive proof that she is that he is the boyfriend, right?
Like there's way more innuendo and taking people's word for it
on the fact that he's a boyfriend or even a like a
>> Um Destiny knows that her boyfriend used to participate
in some of the stuff with her. Like she has a partner who participated
in some of the stuff with her. There's no proof that it's solo
for sure as far as I know. >> That's a good point. >> Uh
he has said it though. I think he said that they were in some
kind of relationship for it.
>> he I believe he said that they uh she'd said things
to him IRL and if he were to dox her it would his IRL life.
>> concretely like determining who it was like in her life
though. Yeah, you're right. That's just going to be like speculation
at the end of the day. Even if you think it's like more likely
one way or another, >> it's kind of going to be >> a
little bit wise,
right? >> But yeah, there's just no explicit proof. And
like the funny thing is is
you wanted the DOJ definition. I mean I don't really particularly
I will just be your pay
>> $3 at elto toto guy got banned on your discord for posting
a leftover 3 link that is directly relevant to the streamer content.
>> Uh okay.
Well, we'll see.
I'll maybe look at that in just a little bit. Sorry, somebody
sent a donation about someone who got banned. Uh, human trafficking
defined. Human trafficking is a crime involving the exploitation
of a p of a person for labor, services, or commercials. The trafficking
victim's protection act of 2000 and it subsequent reauthorizations
recognized and defined two primary forms of human trafficking.
Trafficking is the recruitment, harboring, transportation provision
obtaining, patronizing or soliciting of a person for the purpose
of a commercial act in which the commercial act commercial act
is induced by force, fraud or coercion or in which the person
induced to perform such an act has not attained 18 years of age.
So it seems like probably any time you're participating in this
where the person performing the act is under 18 is going to be
defined as trafficking,
>> Well, no, that's not true, right? Because it's going
to be you're going to be the person who's pushing it forward,
right? there's going to be some kind of like recruitment, harboring,
transportation provision, obtaining, patronizing, or soliciting,
right? Isn't the person who's being charged is like putting their
first foot forward and they're the person who's like organizing
this and they're inducing the minor to do it. >> So, if
it is actually Rose going ahead and doing it herself and then
well, well, he's my boyfriend. He's also he's also being involved,
right? >> He would have to he would have to not be involved
if he's overage. She would have to not be involved in any of
the soliciting anything, right? Like he would he would have to
not be involved at all. If he's involved at all, it would automatically
default to sex trafficking. Like if he helps even cuz I think
I think the the inducement by force fraud or coercion is only
relevant if you're above 18. You're below 18. It seems like automatically
would flip that on to if he's helped. If Rose did it all herself,
then yeah, I agree with you that it wouldn't be trafficking.
>> But even if it helps, he has to solicit her. If she
asks for help to like film the video, she's listening to him.
She's requesting that he help make the video, right? I'm not
talking about the last part. If she's if she's under age of 18,
yeah, it's like that part's met, but the first section of the
definition. You see where I'm going with that? >> I see
where you're going. I don't know that solicited here is the person
who is part who is uh like selling the service. I feel like this
could be soliciting like for a a customer as well, unless I'm
maybe I'm totally misreading. >> Soliciting of a person
for the purpose of commercial
presumably that that person is the person committing the suspect,
right? >> Providing let's say, right? I guess soliciting
of a person for the purpose of providing a Sure. Sure. Sure.
Maybe maybe we could assume that because uh patronizing on the
other side is um transportation recruit. patronizing of a person
for the purpose of a commercial would be that you're you're paying
for it to happen, right? Even if you're not >> as patronizing
would be the other side, but I somehow I feel like somehow like
marketing if you were if you were finding people for her like
to have sex with her that would be that to me and that seems
like the most likely thing is that they he was finding people
for her or would have been some a part there or some part there.
>> it's going to come down to whether it was at her at
her be behest, right? Or at her request. Yes. Yep.
>> I don't know. Personally, I just feel like I just feel
like the uh the trafficking thing is something that Destiny's
like thrown out there in the same way that Destiny's talked about
like him being a honey potter or something like that. It's something
he's thrown out on the first day just as part of the solo bad
solo bad solo bad narrative. He's going after Ethan Klein. He's
like attacking him. It's a big distraction. Attacking Assan.
He's completely unrelated to this. Attacking Kiwi Farms. Attacking
Solo. attacking anybody else to kind of like kind of distract
from the core issue that he likely has sees Sam, right? I I just
read it as part of that. But that's all like what like theory
of mind read. >> Yeah. Well, I mean that is what he's doing.
He always he always floods the zone. He always gives people like
something to attack, right? He needs something to attack for
his audience because his audience is always going to be criticizing
people. If he doesn't give his audience a target, they'll criticize
him. So, he's just always got to give them a new target to go
after. Always, always, always going with it.
>> Just as a as a little aside, I thought this Deeperama
tweet hit it perfectly. Okay. Personally called the police on
Solo over 300 times since the 17-year-old story broke. So Destiny
can go ahead and stop asking why we're not going after Solo after
him. Okay. Thank you, Deeperama. Doing the work we all need done.
Okay, listen. Destiny,
>> look at the new one. Hold on. There's a new Deeperama
tweet. In the spirit of fairness, I filed a CPS report on Queen.
Uh, one second. chat message. I've been working and just tuned
in, so sorry if I'm missing context, but why are you assuming?
He's saying he was trafficking Rose and not the material itself.
Did Loner say human trafficking? Sorry. No, Loner said he's a
trafficker, I guess. Isn't he a big trafficker if she's below
18? And I don't I don't know that you could know that is like
of a person, right? If it's of material, that's just called like
distribution, right? >> You would think so. Yeah, sure.
That would make sense. >> Yeah. Yeah. Um,
there was another part of this that I uh completely thought I
was going to go ask. Um,
listen, I've completely forgot. I apologize. I'm gonna leave
you to it. >> I'll talk to you later, mate. >> No,
no, no. Think of it. Think of it. I >> I probably had more
questions uh thinking of my coverage as well. Um, I thought it
was crazy that Destiny just skips all of the material. And the
shitty thing is I reacted to the Ethan Klein thing first and
I'm like, "Oh, now Ethan is running with like stuff that I think
is important." the fact that Destiny helped do Rose, right? The
fact that she is she is 17 conclusively off of proof that Destiny
himself provided, right? Like Destiny can act like, "Oh, well,
I don't really trust Kiwi Farms." But there's like four different
ways of verifying her age from the proof that Destiny provided.
>> Um, and then there was one other thing. Oh, and that
it's basically like undeniable that he receives material from
her and that it seems like he's keeping it and he just skips
all of this stuff and it's just Oh, and even the group chat stuff,
which I think he's leaned into, I think he's basically I think
from his own testimony, he's sort of proven that there was some
group chat to find Rose, right? Uh I think I think he gets away
with like acknowledging any of those points. And then in order
to like put the cherry on top of that, he actually also goes
and also this is all relevant to my like civil case, so I can't
talk about it. He's just been talking about his civil case non-stop.
He literally like the jud against the judge's orders, he'll talk
about his civil case. He'll literally go and violate the judge's
orders to read a transcript verbatim on somebody else's stream.
It's like, bro, how can you possibly expect us to take it that
seriously when you say you can't talk about your civil case?
>> He can talk about all of this in the DMs of a commentary
YouTuber, but as soon as people like want to clarify what exactly
he meant in those DMs, suddenly he's like, well, you know, the
core I I don't really I don't think I can say anything else.
I don't think Well, you've already said it. Destiny has still
not learned. I said this earlier when I was on stream. Destiny
is just still not learned that Discord DMs can be uh can be leaked.
people will leak things you say and send on Discord. One day
he'll figure it out. One day he'll realize. But yeah, until then.
Um Oh, yeah. I I Dude, I was so like I was so disappointed by
the angle that Destiny took with this cuz you you're right. He
like doesn't address anything that's being discussed. Um I don't
know. You said earlier about did I think that it was funny like
some of the clips about Ethan. I just kind of I might find that
funny, but it's already stuff that I've seen on Snock like two
years ago. And so it's just like it kind of it it's ringing like
an old bell that I don't really care about myself >> and
I just huge distraction. >> So like the Yeah, it's a distraction.
I keep I keep saying like I dude dude holy even that is a and
if if Destiny can expose one more the FBI gave him a deal. Okay,
if you can expose one more they wipe the slate clean for him.
Okay. They destroy all of his charge. Yeah. All he has to do
is expose one more. Okay. One more climb and he's got it. He's
off the hook. It's like, no, that's not how >> it
equivalent exchange from Full Metal Alchemist. Okay. >> Yeah.
Exactly. >> He's got to he's got to catch three to like
set himself free. >> But he just Yeah. >> Yeah. But
for me, it was just like I when I when I was live, I just described
it all as like he's like just jangling keys for people who already
like him or, you know, maybe want to like hate Ethan. It's just
all key jangling, but he doesn't respond to much of what Ethan
is saying. It's like, >> dude, I tweeted out earlier as
well, especially about him like moral frogging about like, oh,
this is all from Kiwi Farms. This is all from He leaked that
information so that Kiwi Farms could find her. >> Yes.
Yes. >> Was he trusting Kiwi Farms post then? >> Yeah.
What was this at that point, too? >> Like he apparently
>> And he even Yeah. Well, he even says it. He's like,
uh, are we forgetting? There's a quote from him in one of his
streams where he's like, "Are we forgetting that I'm the person
who leaked this to Kiwi Farm so that they could like find her?
Do you really think I thought she was below 18 when I was the
one who leaked this information that let them find her?" It's
like, "What are you what do you think you're cooking here? I
have no idea."
>> So, yeah.
I think that was the first stream where he went over it and talked
about it. I think it was like the the first stream that he actually
like just started discussing stuff. Crazy thing to admit. insane
thing to admit. Um,
yeah, dude. Do you think this is going to like result in like
a back and forth? Is Destiny actually going to go on Ethan Klein's
podcast?
maybe. I think at some point I I don't know why. Um, at some
point they have to realize like Hassan's their greater enemy,
right? You would think
like I I just pointed this out that like Hassan is literally
Hassan is like God's most blessed creature. Hassan is like literally
he did nothing. He's just done nothing. He just sits back and
like these two the two people who've been like trying to destroy
his life for the past two years just turned against each other
and now they're just trying to kill each other and sitting back
like looking around. He didn't do [__] Hashan Hassan
just shows up and he he gets to win like God just decided he
was blessed.
It's crazy. >> Just slides into the victory. Yeah. I I
don't know if they will. I don't know if they will. Especially
with the attacks that uh Destiny's made on like Ethan's like
CPS, like digging into his old Reddit accounts as well, like
digging into Ela, digging into what his dad, the crew, all the
[__] ringing all the bells that Ethan hates >> when
he even feels like other people
>> Do we really think that they're gonna like what? Chummy
up again. >> No, I don't think so. Did you not Did you
see this? Because this was wild. This is um the same Twitter
account that everybody's been tracking that shows um that shows
Ethan Klein's dad interacting with stars. Also, there's the same
there's the same name that has an account on and it's got a one
pin and it's a so like it seems to indicate that his dad was
looking at looked up a Klein pinup and
decided to save that. That was the one thing that I saw and I'm
like o
that's like uh like Destiny might have just shaken up this family
a little bit. Okay, it's possible. >> Oh my god. What the
[__] is this, >> dude? I thought you were just
pulling up. I didn't realize this was the him. >> No, it's
this. >> Holy [__] Ethan's relationship with
his parents. He's been quite public about it cuz they publicly
feuded. Has been a little bit kind of little bit >> Yeah.
You saying this was like a rage shirt? Like his son had offended
him that day. Like I'll show you. I'll show
>> Let's let's pull up your wife. Okay. Your sexy wife.
I'll show you, Ethan. Very, very disturbing stuff, I gotta
>> it could have been worse to be fair. For a split second,
I thought it was uh I thought it was an ace of spades.
So, uh, you know, >> Oh, yeah. Could be worse. Could be
worse. It's a ace of clubs. Not quite the same thing. >> I
see your your your nose is keen for that. Okay. You sense that?
you. I didn't even think about that. I fairly well adjusted person.
I didn't even think about this at all. >> You thought about
pulling this on up on stream, buddy boy. Okay. Don't try and
impugn me. All right. >> This was like W clubs and you're
like ace of spades question mark. >> Get the hell. Anyway,
I'm not black new. [__] I'm getting one guy by your
chat. All right. Um, >> wait. What is What does that mean?
BNWO.
>> Do you recognize that? >> Yeah.
I got educated on what it meant the other day. The literally
the other day. Okay.
>> You can go over You can literally >> educate me
on what that meant. >> I I'm sorry. You got one guy by
and I don't even know what that means. Could you just educate
me really quick since you just got educated? >> You you
>> Good times. Good times. Good times.
All right. Where were we? Where were we going? We got Oh, we
were watching the loader box thing. Dude, I don't want to um
I don't want to pile on to this because I I think Lonerbox like
I don't doubt that Lonerbox despises Destiny. I think there is
like a big separation of how he sees like his online politics
and his personal life. And I think personal life-wise he couldn't
like dislike Destiny more. So much so that he won't interact
with him for the online stuff, but I think he tries to keep like
some of the online stuff disjoint. And it probably leads to moments
like this. I just I feel like I wanted more engagement here.
Oh, Hutch raided into him. I wonder if Hutch watched this. Did
Hutch watch the Ethan piece? Cuz I'd love to see that.
Can I get Do we have a Hutch stream? Was there a Hutch stream
on this? Anybody got a Hutch link? A Hutch timestamp? Why? Cuz
I want to No. Hutch rated into Loader Box. Hutch rated into Loader
Box. Hutch rated into loader box. I just want to see what Hutch
had to say about the Ethan video if you watched it. I just love
to see it.
Listen, I want to see all of this stuff. Are we still on Kylo?
I think Kylo was on Wick tonight. Maybe maybe she made a comment.
I'm guessing there were super chats in any case, right? Probably
super chats that got ignored, but I'm guessing there were super
chats. Uh YouTube.com
she was on I believe she was on this tonight, right? >> Well,
by and large we like Yeah. political violence
>> and just try. >> You do. >> Um I don't want
to keep herite too long. Uh Deb, if you want to stay, you're
you're more welcome. But Herd, can you tell people who you are,
where they can find you, all these, and I'll I'll I'll release
the hostage here. So, go ahead. >> Are you a hostage? >> Oh,
right. The Z thing. I did want to check that out. See, Z responding
to some stuff. Let's see. Let's see. Uh PSA leftists are not
on our Oh, dude. I heard Mike from PA was going off on people,
actually. I heard Mike from PA was going crazy with some stuff.
I might have to go check out his Twitter account. I forget exactly
what was going on there. Does anyone know what I'm talking about?
Was Mike like basically arguing for deplatforming?
Am I crazy? Uh, leftists are not on our team. They're just as
bad as MAGA. If you're a person that takes winning elections
seriously, then stop engaging with their content. They think
this is a game and it's not a game. Winning the midterms is serious
and needs to stay and needs to stay c stay focus. Don't let people
like this distract you from our shared goal, which is to beat
Trump and MAGA. Why are you promoting a
Our organization takes any allegation of this nature extremely
seriously. At the same time, we believe it's important to uphold
the principle that every individual is entitled to due process.
At this stage, no evidence has been presented that substantiates
these claims. Until and unless credible evidence is brought forward,
we will not be making decisions based solely on unverified allegations.
Oh, substance goes ahead and throws in Okay, the tsunami person
is out of control. That's out of control.
That's insane.
I hesitate because I know this person, this person's a well-known
snarker, okay? Sadame Snark Omni. Okay. But Jesus Christ, I am
I'm feeling an urge, an inkling, an urge to repost.
Am I strong enough to not snark here? Am I strong enough to not
I'm not I'm not strong enough. I'm not strong enough. I have
to do it. I have to do it. I'm sorry. I has to be done. Okay.
I have to retweet that tweet. It's too funny. It's just too funny.
Oh, hold on.
Ozel's saying, "Look at this. Look at this.
Breaking new alleged TPUSA scandal at Turning Point USA events
garners millions of views. A new alleged scandal for TP USA has
garnered millions of views. That's the same thing twice. You
just put this in this. This was the same this guy using AI to
tweet.
I have written before about this frat boy party culture at Turningoint
USA along with the alleged alleged
cover up by Turning Point USA action co
Tyler Ber of an employee assault on August 5th 2025. Former TPSA
employee Morgan Ariel accused Emily Emily saves USA. You got
fingered in the middle of a hotel lobby at a TPS. Okay, so it's
using that
as of writing this article. This posted to be viewed by over
1.2 million time on X over 1.2 2 million times. Ariel went on
to say in another video, "Why is TPOS like this? Charlie Kirk,
why do you platform and promote degenerate feminist horrors who
have sex in the lobbies of your events with teenagers?" So, this
is this is taking like somebody talking in a tweet and take it
seriously. This is obviously also just AI. I'm weak weak.
After you look into the Turning Point rabbit hole, you'll never
be the same again. Oh, so Z's perfectly fine propagating totally
unsubstantiated allegations against other people against Charlie
Kirk, but against Destiny. No, no, no, no. We need to let the
process play itself out.
Very interesting. Very interesting. Wow, that's crazy. Okay.
Oh, we're going to read this article. And is there any other
Are we done our snarking for the night? Have we finished snarking?
>> Nothing. You guys can't see what I'm looking at. It's
fine. It's fine. It's
>> Hello. Oh, I was looking at uh a super chat from that
lost guy who was on the stream and saying, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
>> Um, okay.
>> Call it. >> No, I didn't see that. Cleaning with
a Q, Kathy. I didn't see that, Kathy. But,
>> whatever. I'm sure there will be a message at some point
soon. I think there's going to be a message. I think. >> And
number three, all of this is just stuff that you were repeating
verbatim that you don't keep. And four, there's not even a way
that I could prove this. Like I don't know what I'm supposed
to do. Like do do you want to come through and go through my
entire computer, my entire folder structure? Like I don't even
know what I could possibly even say other than no and then you
going well what about this? Well, no. Like it's such a stupid
argument. Um like if it was again, hey, listen, people want to
contact authorities. I'm all for that. Again, I haven't said
it. Will Mac want to call authorities because he thinks use [__]
go for that's fine. I just don't know why the [__]
you would make public videos about all this that I for a number
of reasons is impossible for me to respond to for no other reason
getting swatted in FBI constantly. three because I have an active
civil case going that is directly related to some of these conversations
which and again >> talk taking over the panel scene and
making wick watch when dude I don't know panels can kind of be
goofy I would like to host some panels but I need to like tap
into some other communities here I was like talking to lactoid
a little bit and I wanted to talk to like lacto and the lost
guy I would just like to have that conversation can we get can
we get all the proof on the on the table here I I need proof
of some things this Lawson guy is totally fine going out and
lying about me about things I've done and he's got no proof to
back it up and that's what DJers are comfortable doing. I want
any one of these people to raise their head up and just come
show me like how you have proof. Why is this Why is this like
defensive doxing? Why is it all okay? Can Can anybody make sense
of this or I I would love to have some conversations on that
as far as like other topics go? We'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
Yeah, it's just such an unbelievably crazy bind to sick man and
then pretend that he's making, you know, some type of strong
argument that I'm some kind of online predator based on Ryan
Beard's videos with random in the context of everything else
with him continually trying to normalize
with >> Like, at what point has this ever been the case?
Has there ever ever been a clip of me ever saying, "I think you
should be able to [__] 15 year olds. I think you
should be able to [__] 12-year-olds. I think you
should be able to [__] 17 year olds." Like, that's
what we got from the six or seven clips earlier. Really?
>> Queen live. Thank you for the raid. Welcome, my friends.
Welcome, welcome, welcome. As a designated representative of
Canada, I welcome you, my brothers. I welcome you. We're currently
watching Litterbox for signs of an opinion. Signs of any opinion.
Any opinion at all. We're We're just looking for signs of life
over here. Okay. We're just looking for signs of life. Any signs
of life is fine and holding on to potential child is fine. Then
go ahead and defend this. But just know that is what you're defending.
Those are the facts. Jack, >> I reported this to police
and record your call to the detective. [__] willing
mad crying be so listen the guy's a he's a [__] degenerate
there's no way like listen if you want to be degenerate then
fine then [__] a go for it but my brother in Christ
okay we are two keys in a degenerate pod and I think you're >> okay
hold on litter box finally does so after this okay we're we're
a little annoyed all I wanted was Lerbox watching the section
that he had uh was otherwise skipping right the death he was
skipping it looks like Loadbox goes back and watches that on
his own
excuse me so Listen, feels like we're going good here than I
am. But that's seriously the thing. >> Oh, also guys, we
are 11 minutes away from the end of the stream. I forgot to show.
[__] Guys, we're uh we're I think six subs away.
Something like six subs away from another hour on the stream.
I need that extra hour. Get that extra hour in. Okay, I love
you guys. Thank you very much for being here tonight. We're six
subs away. Another hour on the stream. Get them in. Get them
in. Get them in. Six. >> The embarrassing part for me putting
all this video together was I think I was I might have actually
been out edged by this guy. Okay, I thought I was the edge lord.
And this guy is out. He's out edgewooding me on pedophilia which
was supposed to be my domain according to this guy. >> Wait,
if you if you like Destiny, do you think he's smart and funny
and awesome? >> That is like an accurate point. Like Ethan's
Ethan's like jokes actually outstripped Destiny by miles. Okay.
If Ethan ever gets a credible accusation,
>> You are supporting someone who attracted 15-year-old
who shared compromising of the beginning of 15year-old sent him
>> compromising. These are pictures posted publicly on
social media of people at the beach again. Like what the [__]
He's acting like [__] news from kids which maybe
he I don't know. >> He has held on knowing there's a chance
of chopping off for six months and never reported it to the floor.
>> No idea what's on my computer. You have no idea what
I reported to authorities. You have no idea about literally any
of this. Again, you're just reading down Snark Freds or Kiwi
Farms that he sexually assaulted a woman on camera. >> What
do you want me to do? Do you want me to go back in time and kill
myself? What the hell about comment and tell you got all this
thing wrong? You're lying all this [__] Bro, >> I
just want to know what Lorox is doing instead of reacting to
the video. >> Controversial facts. >> True. I do
agree with that. Okay, I am glad. Like if you're playing a video
game or something, put that up on screen. At least let me see
the video >> I guess we got to have this back and forth.
This one is his. >> You are [__] up to defend
this guy. And like I guess I don't know if you're being asked
or misled, but like watching the video that Aba made with all
this context out here and he he's accusing me. I'm not doing
research, but why did you brush over the screenshot of him confessing
to knowingly having potential child on that is absolutely not
what I quote unquote confessed to. And again, I didn't know these
[__] obvious making jokes and [__] and
putting little W faces around this, but I knew that William publish
all [__] conversations on this, right? It's so >> I'm
going to feel really bad if Lonerbox was like discussing, you
know, like a family member's like treatment from illness or something
while this is happening and he's just letting >> Listen,
there's reasons he could not be reacting. I'm just like >> wondering
what it is exactly >> at El Pto.
>> I I don't know. I don't know if we're going to do that.
I don't know what El Toto to put in the Discord. Okay. What did
he do? What did that guy do?
From from El Toto to to I don't even I don't even know how to
get this guy's name up on my [__] So
saying that a private conversation I'm having with a guy relating
to all this is then public like okay well now you need to line
by line then everything should Jesus what the [__]
was a public [__] statement. Not to say that like
I'm revealing some, you know, explicit whatever [__]
detail, but more so that just like obviously if I'm going to
know that there's going to be public release phrasing a lot more
careful be a lot more precise my statements here. But he's acting
like this was sometime
>> it's possible that that guy should get untimed out and
he might not have he might have been timed out mistakenly
in some way possibly. Okay, possibly. Also looks like timed out.
Get [__] >> interrogation to be released and
then I like failed the interrogation. But again, despite all
of that, listen, you want to call you report whatever then [__]
you will get it. That's fine. I don't I just don't know why you
make public videos on expecting me to be able to publicly respond
to prove that I don't have stuff on my computer. I don't know
what that looks like. Never commented on that. You only commented
on things I got wrong. Right. More the whole context. You're
the whole context. >> What looks to me to be a consistent
long-term highly motivated premeditated child predator. That's
what he looks like to me. >> Consistent, long-term, highly
motivated child predator. Okay. >> He's throwing the >> There's
only one consistent long-term child predator that I'm aware of
in this circle. I didn't want to bring this up,
>> you can see my buttons are open. >> Oh my goodness.
I was 16 years old here. >> Wow. Look at you guys here.
>> Dad's 21 and I'm 16. >> Dude, that if that happened
today, bro, you would know. I know. >> Now, to be fair,
I don't know. Maybe they weren't [__] up. >> Well,
you know what? I was more mature than he was. >> I believe
that. I actually do believe >> But look at her. I mean,
she just came off the cover of >> dude
between Willie M. If you've got still got the >> We didn't
get time out. He just left.
>> Thoughts on the exchange between Willie Mack and Destiny.
So, it sounds like Willie Mack has if you still if
>> Oh, hello.
>> Hello, Private Huff with five gifted. We are one gifted
away from another hour on the stream, guys. Thank you very much,
Private Huff. Actually, hold on. 35. No, we're not. We actually
got there. We actually got there all on our own. Let's go. Thank
you guys very much. I forgot about the five from Verra to free
all Toto. But apparently that guy didn't get banned in the first
place. He just left. So five for nothing, Verra. But thank you
very much. >> A minor. Then that would mean that if you've
got still got those videos, that would mean that you're possessing
or whatever the it's called. Uh and I think he answered something
like uh he's asked if he has it and he's like depends on why
you're asking. Lol.
Uh, no. That's not That's not it. It was depends on why you're
asking. But yes, I did save everything. That was the answer.
Depends on why you're asking. But yes,
but yes, I did copy everything from those DMs. >> It didn't
I couldn't tell if he said that my lawyers told me to keep a
hold of everything or if like maybe they want me to keep a hold
of everything. I don't know if that was ever clarified.
all seems a bit >> We could just go look it up. We could
just go look at the D. Like literally Willie posted them. They're
in Ethan's >> All seems a bit odd to me. But,
you know, I mean, I guess if it's legally relevant, then they're
probably going to be like they're going to have to track her
down like properly, aren't they? If if there's actually like
a a police investigation or they're going to have to get >> Yeah,
she's apparently selling child. Yeah, they're going to have to
track her down. It seems like no matter what Desi did in terms
of saving this and keeping it and whether or not he called the
police at the right time, she was definitely selling child. They're
absolutely going to track her down. >> Her like uh they're
going to have to get her like birth certificate or something,
>> They're going to have to get her birth certificate,
dude. She's already proven 17. That's not even a question.
>> Box forgot he's a character in the story kind of. >> I
guess the the truth as ally, but yeah. >> That's so crazy.
Yeah, you could not do that today. I mean, that would be just
like, wo.
>> No, he's not covering this as if it was an Israeli missile
strike. He's covering it like nothing else I've ever seen him
cover. I like Loner Box's coverage. When I watched him on Israel
stuff, he would always go and like keep digging into stuff and
make sure like he got information to like I don't know, come
to some sort of like balanced conclusion, right? That's why I
like watching Loerbox before. This is like not the same at all.
Oh, you
this you left this can and can complain all you want, but yes,
he was always very informed. I like watching his stuff because
he would always go and check a bunch of this is like the opposite
of the loader box coverage I like watching. I don't know what
the [__] happened. He's like, I guess it seems like
this could be happening, but like even though I could go look
that up directly, I'm not really going to go and look that up
directly, buddy. Josh Kosh. I would just think that probably
the thing you might
take some solace in is that probably
there could have been Discord subpoenas to hold Destiny's data
even before the leaks had come.
Not subpoenas. Um there could have been so basically if you make
a threat towards like a political figure, there's a chance that
you get put on um there's like a specific Patriot Act related
data hold that happens where if you're making potentially like
if you're uttering terroristic threats, they could go to a bunch
of different tech platforms and say, "Hey, we need you to hold
this person's data. We're watching them." They don't it's not
a subpoena on the data yet, but it is like, "Hey, you're actually
going to avoid your retention policies. You're going to retain
data on this person, right?" So, there's a chance that like that
data has been getting retained for way longer. Okay, you make
jokes about how Trump should have actually caught that bullet
and the world would be a better place if Trump hadn't leaned
backwards. There's a chance the 30 days removal from a CDN, not
their internal storage, right? No, the 30 days is also their
guaranteed. The 30 days is just the guarantee. We're going to
have the store for 30 days.
That's just the that's the only guarantee. Um, by the way, guys,
that's not that's not they're allowed to look at the data. That's
like, hey, just start retaining the data, right? just start retaining
the data and we might need to subpoena it later. In any case,
I think it seems obvious that by the time December rolls around,
like not obvious, I I think there's reason to hope that subpoenas
or uh not even subpoenas, preservation requests could have hit
some of those providers before stuff was deleted. I think >> we're
in San Francisco. We went up to >> Maybe he thinks his
dad has a pet, too, I guess, and that's why he's justifying calling
me a pet. Maybe he's willing to take that leap. But I don't know.
Um my closing thing on this is I don't think Ethan is a pet.
In fact, I'm gonna be honest. I was going to probably like 70%
of these videos. >> Uh Josh Kosh. Yes, I think um some
people were avoiding saying anything about Willie. Okay, because
I I understand when you already don't like Willie. It seems like
sour to go. Why do Willie Mack even publish that video, right?
I understand you want to avoid the appearance of sour. But factually,
okay, Willie cares far more about clout than catching child predators.
He wouldn't publish that video like within a day or two of actually
contacting the police if you had any concern about right like
I'm sorry you wouldn't do that. You wouldn't do that. There's
no way you expect the police to have a uh like any kind of what
would it be called when they want to go like pick up hard drives
or something. I think that would be a subpoena or something,
right? Like there's no way you'd expect the police to have already
dealt with it. Like obviously Willie cares way more about his
own clout than about uh or clearing his own name, clearing himself
of the the destiny stink. Okay. Then he cares at all about what
happens to Destiny or what actually like if justice is done.
Doesn't give a >> I thought it was I thought they were
[__] funny because I appreciate old internet edgy
humor. Okay. I didn't think a lot of things were funny. I don't
think ethic I think he's intentionally uh um predatoring. There's
a verb there like we're praying. >> Wait. Uh I don't trust
any data retention policy. I go on it'll be saved for as long
as feasibly possible. That is what a data retention policy is.
A data retention policy is just a guarantee. What happens with
basically all data? uh anybody who's got anything remotely close
to like an updated um like file store database of any kind, you'll
just soft delete things. You'll have the chance to recover it,
but basically like once it needs to be replaced like right, it'll
it'll just be soft deleted. It'll be marked as something that
can be written over. So once it's written over, it's written
over, but it might sit there forever depending on, you know,
how things are zoned or what's going on right on children or
trying to normalize children to audience. Although I will admit
that that Boston Barber one, that's everything one. I really
tested the boundaries there. That was really pushing pushing
boundaries on that one. But um the the the annoying thing is
I don't think I don't even think I'm the pedal. I don't think
you can possibly think that. Um like I have had not to get into
the weird whatever territory, but I've hooked up with a lot of
people over the last 15 years. I say there's like a pattern of
children or whatever is just absolutely not true. Some of my
biggest egirl dramas have been with women that are basically
my age. The end of war [__] This girl was like two
years younger than me. Okay. The idea that there's like some
huge pattern established of young women of praying on people
is absolute. And plenty of people have tried to say this over
and over again. Every single >> It's a good thing that
some crusades are a bit less effective than others. [__]
sake. Fbombs. The guy who actually
was kind of like a known chatter contributor actually. He would
he would donate as well to communities like minor child logics
and everything. Started up a stream, had some conversations,
you know, was trying to get things started, but just decided
to nuke all of it on a really crusade against progressive victory
and now he's saying sunlight is here because Hassan has covered
it. >> Wait, is this talking is the video literally talking
about progressive victory? Interesting. The secret
influencers exposed. Okay. and Taylor Loren's doing a scoop.
>> Is it really interesting? >> Dark Money Group.
The Progressive Victory Obsession. >> Progressive Victory
was weird. It was dark money.
Um I think it was small enough scale that like probably it wasn't
offsetting things or anything. It was just weird. It was like
um it was dark money. It was It was just like a weird thing.
You didn't If you don't know where the money's coming from, you
don't know the uh incentives of the people giving you the money.
That's just facts, man. That's just facts. I I don't know why
people get mad about that. It's like it's weird. I don't begrudge
any creator who took the money, right? You took that money. I
I get it. I understand.
Especially if they tell you that you don't have to say anything,
>> They should be made to mark their posts with paid ad.
>> I think you should have to disclose. >> Yeah,
there should be more transparency, shouldn't there? There should
be more
>> there. Okay. Okay. Litterbox did this, but I believe
Lerbox was one of the late pickups to progressive victory, right?
Am I crazy or did Litterbox I don't think Litterbox was there
as an early pickup? I think he was there like quite a bit after.
Like Really like came on quite a bit later than most people.
And there was a valid criticism that they were not disclosing
that they were being paid by PV. Wick was being paid by PV for
quite a while before he did before he disclosed. That's just
facts. I don't know why people would act like that's not facts.
It's not as if the work I did for these guys is on the progressive
victory page published by them with my content with their look
with their logo and [__] So dark dark as hell thing.
>> Oh, he he misunderstands
where the money It's not dark that the money is going to you
guys. It's dark where the money is coming from that goes into
the pack. That's what's the dark money. Oh, that's rough. That's
rough. you. To be fair, you guys were shocked when you found
out that I >> That's [__] There is not a single
leftist in the world that doesn't understand the problem with
dark money.
>> Millionaires and billionaires give all this money to
super PACs. I I vaguely remember somebody with this voice talking
about this a lot. Okay.
Progressive victory sometimes.
you know, you thought you most of you thought that I went to
Ohio to do canvasing in a different country just uh you because
I felt like it just was a nice thing to >> Time at [__]
Falls is always the same three or four stupid clips that come
out over and over again. Um I look forward to making the same
type of video I guess like two or three or four years from now
when somebody else decides to dig it all up again. Like by that
point like my my clips on on talking about miners will be old
enough for me to [__] the clips themselves and for
it to not be pedophilia. So um I don't know if Ethan feels like
he has to disavow me because he wants to lose like the Destiny
puppet allegations. Uh there are easier ways for him to do that
if he wants. >> Yes. Oh my god, you idiots. Yes, I know.
Apparently, he skipped a bunch cuz the video's like 35 minutes
long. Yeah, he skipped things. So, yeah, don't worry. Don't worry.
Don't worry. >> Drop the Destiny puppet alig. >> I
hope he listens to the other video. >> Argue about something.
Um, we he could call me a goo. >> Is it I don't even know
even if he retains a bunch of that video. I'm like, you didn't
comment on it. You kind of just rebroadcast. >> Sono, he
could make fun of my laning in League. Uh, you know, there's
lots of things he can trick the [__] out of Like
I don't know why he's so weakwilled and so spineless that he
gets into his crew immediately and he gets into his base instinct
immediately and in a desperate attempt to throw off the destiny
allegations he decides to just start going in on me on like probably
>> just to be clear I've talked to Lerbox a little bit
in private like in terms of I think he could sweep progressive
victory he could be like he could act like a total right there
and act like oh dark money well I said it where I was getting
paid right that could be but I will say in terms of like does
he like destiny is he trying to get in with Destiny I I just
don't see that angle at all. Um, so if anybody's like thinking
that, I think that's like a very goofy angle to come at this
from >> one of the worst topics. >> On a personal
level, he's like very much not a fan of Destiny >> that
he could go in on me for. I don't know why the [__]
you would do this. Like, bro, like there's some [__]
secret pedile ring. The only reason you know I'm there is cuz
you're in the [__] meetings. Like, holy [__]
These videos are insane for him to make these types of accusations.
So, come on, bro. I don't know. Like, now the annoying thing
is I know that since I responded to this, I'm sure he has to
be responsible about me. I don't know if it's just going to literally
be us. >> Said he skipped because it's related to his case.
Okay. >> Um, going back and forth through whoever has the
deeper snark threads, whoever has the deeper DB farms threads.
Um, and to and we're just going to rehash that for the next like
two weeks or two months or year or whatever until he gets bored.
I don't know how long it takes to talk out. >> Um, but
yeah, I will say thumbs up to the anti community though cuz I
know the snarkers and the TV farmers love this type of fighting.
Uh, congratulations Ethan. I know they love it. They're loving
the back and forth right now. You're giving the best show possible.
The absolute best show they could possibly hope for. And you
know, I guess at least I'm making some money out of it. You're
making some money out of it. At the end of the of day, we don't
give a [__] about anything besides that, right? If
that's what this is all about, then good job. But um, >> that
was me clapping.
based based mean >> snarkers and vans whatever whatever
label you think applies
I'm done with all this today for now and then I'm sure AB star
killer is already working on his next research dog
>> defamation he know
>> um 20 something
>> and he says a exciting
>> are you looking forward to it >> okay we'll go
we'll do this Ethan just did his apology lucky >> I'm going
to use the bathroom real quick give me a second Yeah, we saw
that with >> But but this one, however, is from Rose and
it is pretty weird. Uh this is from 22. She says, "I'm probably
getting my braces off in a couple weeks." What what image does
that ponder in your mind? Right. And he says, "A
exciting.
Are you looking forward to it?" He's talking to her like she's
a child. But okay, there's nothing explicit here, right? So fair
enough. So, I I am making a sincere apology for getting >> the
braces is not
the strongest angle there, but okay. Didn't denims have braces
when she was like in her mid20s.
She used to stream with braces, but >> this wrong. Now,
while two of the screenshots were not attributed to Rose, my
mistake. I still don't know why. And and I feel like Destiny
and his friends like Abba who who are making videos defending
him are avoiding this fact that he told Willie Mack three times
users are rising up in the chat >> that he had child on
his on his hard drive. Let me refresh your memory >> while
sending me a screenshot of the alleged. So I asked to confirm
if he just did that. If you were sending me this, I'm guessing
you still have that video. Destiny replies, "Depends on why you're
asking, but yes, I created copies of all." So here right above
he's acknowledging he says yeah that's absolutely insane to >> okay
I went to the bathroom right as loner box answered the bra the
braces thing the braces point is not um the braces is just one
of the pieces one of the yellow flags where it's like oh how
often do people get braces right and at what age do they usually
get braces I want to say it was like 70% of people get braces
like young like young young right
like braces are not common amongst adults people do get adult
braces it is not conclusive it is just one of those things that
throws a little flag in your face and you're like, "Ah, okay.
Okay." >> Think about him doing all this if she was 17.
He thinks it's funny. So, he knows she's might have been 17.
He's saying it right here. And then Willie >> Yeah. Obviously.
Sorry. Anybody who thinks the point about braces is a good point
in a vacuum is
just a piece of a greater constellation. Obviously, if I was
sitting here telling you that because of braces, you should have
thought Rose was underage. No. Like, the biggest red flag is
from those Twitter DMs, right? That's the biggest red flag. >> Mac
being extra careful to make sure that he's not misquing Destiny.
>> Assuming they're real. Assuming they're real. I feel
like there's a lot of reason to think they could be. >> Says,
"Just to confirm, you're saying you still have this video of
a
engaged in activity on your hard drive." And he says, and I will
tell you directly,
yes. He says Ys
when somebody asks you do you have >> Hey, there's the
there it is laid over for Litterbox. Litterbox said, "Oh, I don't
remember exactly what he said." So yeah, depends on why you're
asking, but yes, I created a copy of all of our messages and
everything when that course case started, which by the way is
2 months after he was told she was a minor, right? That's just
absolutely insane to think. If you're sending me this, I'm guessing
you still have that video. That is
that is unequivocally
but yes I created a copy. He says yes this is him categorically
saying okay categorically that I had not deleted that that child
at the point that I was sued by Pixie and I retained a copy of
it right everything but yes I created a copy of all of our messages
and everything when that court case started. It is just conclusive.
It is irrefutable that Destiny is saying yes here. Like it's
not close. It's there's no room for interpretation. There's not
really room for misspeaking. You would think if somebody's asking,
hey, you still have that child,
right? Like you would think somebody's brain would go, oh, I
need to be really careful to say no, I do not >> child
on your computer.
You always say no. That's a hard and fast rule. And hopefully
it's true. >> And again, equally creepy. He says, "So you
have that video and
>> No, that is funny. What do you What if you do?" Listen,
Destiny's just a really honest guy, okay? Destiny doesn't lie.
He just misrepresents He just misrepresents things. Okay? So,
if he's not lying,
then he's got to say, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, I I have copies of all
that stuff." As he responds, "Uh, depends on why you're asking
because once again, he's implying that under the right circumstance,
he would send this video to Willie Mack." That's what that means.
I don't see any other way to see that. What does that mean? It
depends on why you're asking. Are you trying to tell the police
or are you trying to get off? You're trying to get off. I'll
send it to you. If you're calling, if you're talking about reporting
to the police, then I'm not going to send it to you. But actually,
I will anyway cuz I'm I'm apparently the dumbest person alive.
So, Destiny and ABBA and all these people defending him are avoiding
this critical moment in which when pressed three different times,
he has confirmed yes, I have child on >> this is actually
I don't know if I gave Ethan enough props for how he flowed through
this part of the uh the DMs, right?
Uh this is actually very effective. This is actually really well
done. I can see precisely why Destiny avoided it because Ethan
did a great job with just this specific section. Now I'm like
trying to watch somebody else sort of not respond and said depends
on why you asking
but yes depends on why you're asking but yes I did >> my
computer but to continue on messages and everything when that
court case started. Just to be clear he's admitting to having
alleged Cape downloaded on his computer. He literally has the
video open as I'm talking to him. I go brother there's been allegations
at least since my last video that she was underage and you still
have potential of her. >> So again that's important detail
saying is that people knew that there was a chance people already
we all done known that she might have been underage this whole
time and you still kept it. >> I have an obligation to
preserve relevant evidence etc. So I created backups of all the
important relevant >> please please please another one
of his comments that I want to pay attention to. He's saying
my lawyer told me to keep this potential child for evidence which
is completely not true. And by the way why wouldn't he lie about
it? He's literally he's being confronted for having child at
this point. Why wouldn't he lie? The fact that people are actually
believing him on that is totally insane. The lawyer will not
tell you to keep potential child in your hard drive. Period.
Having the having it is the crime. There is no situation where
private citizen can have videos of minors in se positions on
legally. There's no such >> I don't know anything about
the legal stuff. Is that true? Is he not supposed to keep it?
Uh
how how could I put this? Oh man, I don't know. Uh, I think potentially
criminal and I came up with the the same metaphor independently
for this. Okay. That it's like radioact it's like the graphite
from Chernobyl. Okay. How do I know
that you've got evidence in a case that's a radioactive graphite
from Chernobyl? It's like can if I hand it over to the defense
or the opposing uh the opposing council or the defendant, they
die. Like it's it's like literally radioactive. You cannot hand
it to anybody, right?
It's illegal. It's illegal to possess in any way. There's no
way,
right? There's no way that you could use it in the case. They
don't have authority to use this evidence in the case. So, there's
no reason that a lawyer would tell you you need to preserve that
as evidence for the case. There's it's categorically not a thing.
>> Thing is holding it for evidence. And by the way, if
you were so, you know, concerned about her safety, you should
have reported it to the >> surprised are people surprised
to learn that straight raid's involved in this. Yeah, she is.
Yeah. >> What? What? Why is straight raid being brought
up? Straight raid? I didn't know she's involved in this. What
the [__] What did I
did I miss where straightway was brought up? Where was she brought
>> The lawyer will not tell you to keep potential child
pornography on your hard drive. Period. Having the having it
is the crime. There is no situation where private citizen can
have videos of minors in positions on legally. There's no such
thing as holding it for evidence. And by the way, if you were
so, you know, concerned about her safety, you should have reported
it to >> people surprised. Where are people surprised to
learn that straight raid is involved in this? Yes, she is. Yeah.
where Destiny mentioned trader in the Oh, right. >> Well,
she's actually not. She managed to completely slither away. >> Okay.
I'm uh
buddy, I
slither away. What did she What did she do that was wrong? She
was like a bad friend to Pixie. I'm sorry. Being a bad friend
being a bad friend is not criminal. It's not something you can
have a civil action over. She was a bad friend to Pixie. Yes.
Her slithering away is not for being a bad friend is nothing.
Shut the [__] up. There's actual crimes happening.
There's actual things. Don't focus on straight raid.
What mutant creature mentions straight raid in his chat? I have
to actually see which mutant creature mentioned straight raid
at all.
Whereas straight raid I didn't know she's involved in this. What
the [__] Lol. Well, Destiny just named her for some
reason. I don't know why,
>> but she should be. She was involved in this. Yeah, she
played a big role. She >> in what? It's about Destiny retaining
Straight raid was not consulted. This is about the the child.
This is about the child. Hold on. I mean the combo with straight
raid has Destiny's little confession. Straight raid is involved
in the pixie case. This is not about the pixie case. This is
about something far more serious unfortunately than the pixie
case. Okay. Destiny could have written a check for the pixie
case and walked on.
Right. He can't write a check for this and walk on. This is like
a very very very serious
crime. He's he's uh accused of it's not the same thing. This
is far more serious, far more dangerous to him and Pix and straight
raid has nothing to do with it. >> That person, what can
I say? >> The police 6 months ago when her boyfriend told
you about it, right? Continuing on. >> Think I'm
>> Yes, twisted rope. Obviously, he would assume. Obviously,
we have to assume he could have just written the check and walked
away
to delete it. Lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding destroying.
>> What's funny about that? I don't know if it counts as
hiding, destroying evidence. Well, why don't you ask your lawyer
who he's apparently talked to? So, he says, "I've talked to my
lawyer. They told me to keep potential child, but at the same
time, I don't know if it counts as hiding or destroying evidence.
You didn't discuss that with your lawyer because if you did,
that would be the heart of the conversation you would be having.
So, it sounds to me that you didn't talk to your lawyer, which
is obvious to anyone with a brain because the lawyer would have
said there's a how do I explain this? There's like a phenomenon
going on here, and I don't want to feed into it, but I want to
be accurate." So, I don't know what the proper line is to walk,
but there's this phenomenon where I can tell that you guys are
annoyed at Loner Box. I'm kind of annoyed at Loner Box right
now, okay? But I can tell you guys are annoyed at Loner Box.
And I don't want to feed into that and feed off of that and go
harder on him, but I also want to be accurate with what's going
on, okay? Because I realize I've got a lot of especially Queen
Raid, and I know there's a lot of more lefty people in his audience,
especially the ones who watch on kick and I know they will dislike
box from like a base level. So, I'm trying to be fair,
but like realistically the commentary is incredibly poor right
now. Very poor. Um, he commented earlier how he wasn't sure about
the child thing and then he gets the concrete answer here, right?
You put that together with Willie Mack, Tom, everybody agreeing
that Rose is clearly 17. There's a bunch of a bunch of objective
information that Rose is 17, right?
like like Destiny almost certainly has CSAM had CSAM
on his computer and then in some somewhere in his possession
in a hard drive off off of his computer not connected or something
right so
what I don't what I don't understand is like none of that's being
commented on at all and you could say you don't want to comment
on it oh that's above my pay grade I don't want to comment on
it but then why are we covering this at all right then I don't
know why you're covering it if you just want to comment on like
some of the stuff that's vaguely related to the Pixie case I
just feel like there's such better stuff you could >> Said,
"We need to send this to the judge. We need to send this to the
police. We need to get this off your hard drive. We need to notify
everybody because you are doing a crime right now, sir. And by
the way, I'm sure your lawyer really appreciates you saying that
they told you to keep potential child." I think that that's awesome
and they're going to totally love being implicated in this crime.
And by the way, of all the tiny menu things that you can break
client confidentiality with as an attorney, child having it is
one of them. Now, when Destiny says his lawyer told him to keep
all the evidence relating to the case, the lawyer absolutely
and obviously told him that. Uh maybe that's what it is. him
cause maybe that's why I'm trying not to go like too hard on
the guy cuz like I have some empathy but also
like people do take him quite seriously and if he is going to
comment on it then I do think he probably needs to be a little
sharper a little more >> spoilation that's standard stuff
but what I doubt I would put money on that that he never told
his lawyer that in that body of evidence was potentially a child
having or doing acts it was apparently her having sex with men
but child right potentially there's no lawyer Would you want
her to make a statement? What? What? Would you want me to Would
you want me to make a statement about Would you Are you asking
me if I would want Aaron or Straight Aid to make a statement?
Don't ask me. The Ask um You should ask Pixie that. I don't know.
>> In the country, and I've worked with a lot of them.
That would risk their freedom, their reputation, their license
by not handling that correctly. I'm allowed to delete it. Lol.
I don't know if it counts as hiding/ actually say something.
Mick, rewind the stream, you immediate illiterate.
and then see if I >> Oh god, did he say something like
uh Hold on. Did he say something like I'm doing something in
the background uh because I don't want to shut off off stream.
I'll just watch the stuff in the background maybe. Maybe he's
taking good notes. Uh-oh. This going to apply to me, but I wasn't
watching. Okay, I started watching this uh in the middle. >> Have
I said anything or not? Jesus Christ. I'm not going to repeat
myself every [__] 10 seconds because someone who
has no time for me or my content anyway and I >> Oh, no.
I've been watching for a long time and you've not been commenting.
Uh, Ioh
no that's not rewind and and act like I haven't been talking.
No, you really haven't been talking. I'm sorry. >> I don't
need I don't give a [__] about to just come in and
be like is going to say I don't know. You clearly don't know
because you haven't [__] checked evidence and I replied
talk to
>> unfortunately I checked.
Now I only checked the the part where like this stuff was coming
up but I I did check. >> That seems crazy to me. >> Who
keeps this sort of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing
if they're supposed to or not? Isn't that something you want
to confirm? I continue. You just let me know you have videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still >> Willie being extraordinarily fair.
Once again clarifies for the third time and he says it explicitly
just to confirm. You told me you have child saved on your computer.
You knew it was alleged she was underage and you still have them.
Don't you see how this is [__] up? You cannot be
more clear in the accusation. Now, if you
didn't do any of this, what would your response be to this? It's
like, bro, what the I don't have child porn. What are you talking
about? That's insane, right? What? That's crazy. Let's see what
he says. >> The last message he sent me was one. I don't
even know 100% for age was legitimately less than 18 and these
were >> That doesn't matter. The fact that you're not 100%
sure is the problem. And you have it unc.
>> I'm pretty sure the confidence here to like this is
one of those things where if you're 95% sure, the 5% chance,
okay,
the 5% chance that she's underage is enough to probably do something
crazy. Like at minimum, I think that's enough to clear every
reference you have of this everywhere, right? To be like, "Oh,
that I'm getting it off. I'm getting off my computer. Getting
it out of here." That right.
But possibly for Destiny, even like enough to go to the cops.
Uh, >> we know he's got it. He said he's got >> Nobody
would fly if there's a 5% chance of crashing. And realistically,
would you rather be in a plane crash or have credible accusations
of multiple instances of both receiving uh har like holding uh
possessing and transferring
That's pretty close to me. Those odds are pretty close. Okay.
Would you rather be in a plane crash? Not all plane crashes ended
death. Okay. or would you rather be credibly accused of har of
of possessing and transferring multiple instances of child and
that's that's not like an easy instant answer for me. >> so
basically he's not 100% sure if he has child on his computer.
He's just 99% sure. Got it. Two, I'm pretty sure I have an obligation
to preserve stuff related to my court case. I've talked >> that
part's true generally speak. >> Like are you telling me
that you still have child on your computer? I didn't even know
she was 18 and I have an obligation to maintain all the evidence.
To me, I don't understand. Like, you can you can call Willie
Mack illiterate, but like it's obvious even to the illiterate
that Destiny is holding this material, right? Like he or he's
trying to tell people he is speaking >> my lawyer already
specifically with regards to the Rose. >> That's a lie.
In my humble uh god-like opinion, no, that's it has to be. Or
sue me. God sue me for defamation. He's lying. He never [__]
told his attorney he might have child on his hard drive. That
never happened. And if I'm wrong, God, strike me down with lightning
bolts and may destiny sue me and take me for all I'm worth. This
man never told his attorney that. >> So, he went from I
don't know if I could delete this to my lawyer says it's totally
fine to keep. I don't know the law, but the idea that his lawyer
would tell him to hold on to for a civil case just doesn't seem
likely to me. Law can figure that out. Three, if something were
to come, >> he says Law Tube can figure that out. And funnily
enough, um, Legal Mindset did put out a video on it. >> Legal
Mindset.
>> Loader box going to say a single word or just reream.
Um, I don't know if you heard, he had a whole rant where he called
some guy for saying that he wasn't reacting enough. Okay, >> thank
God Legal Mindset made a video about it. Hell yeah. When in doubt,
Legal Mindset, our spiritual leader >> watched and his
conclusion was destiny is basically if he says if this girl was
a minor, >> which pretty much is confirmed by now according
to Willie Mack, he's >> something to turn over to the authorities.
If hypothetically whenever a political creator is about to give
a hypothetical, you know, you're about to hear some weird. If
hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking
her, get her other dudes on video for >> anti-hypothetical.
He's such a normal person, isn't he, Willie Mack? He's so ordinary.
He's such a regular old dude. >> Well, that's funny. Okay,
Luna. Hey, Lunabos is that talking. Let's go. Yes. What a normal
guy. He's just a fun everyday normal guy, >> you know.
Loves his car, loves his wife, loves his blonde children,
loves churning butter, loves fish, going fishing with his dad
in the woods, knows how to fend off a bear attack,
knows which bear to run away from and which bear to play dead
for. My god, >> there was ever investig. >> Would
you have sex with a child if it >> He knows all the sports.
He knows what happened. He knows who won the football every time.
Andrew completely wiped his go east channel. Yeah, but people
would archive that instantly. Borderbellar, I think that archive
for sure. >> Nuclear bomb from exploding in New York. Would
you? Come on, do the right thing forever. This I >> We've
watched enough of this video that she was 19 at the time and
that's what he thought. Has anyone asked Destiny why Rose was
selling nudes on Twitter? Right. I've never even heard of that.
Why wouldn't she be selling nudes on Only Fans? Is it because
Only Fans makes you verify that you're at least 18 to sign up
and Twitter doesn't? Right. Selling nudes on Twitter is already
a red flag. It's extremely weird. Why aren't you doing it on
Only Fans? The marketplace for this where everybody is. When
these influencers are chatting up their young fans, there's a
almost it's almost a certainty that people are going to lie to
you about their age. And like if you actually want to engage
with them in this extremely risky, borderline activity, you need
to make goddamn sure they're of age. And honestly, over the internet,
I don't even know if that's possible, which is why you just shouldn't
do it, right? Like you can look at someone and be like, "That
person's very young, like maybe 22 at oldest." And you say, "You
know what? I'm not going to [__] engage with this
because I'm 33 years old and I don't want to receive nudes from
minors." But anyway, so far, not the muddy the waters, he hasn't
done anything wrong, right? Okay. Then this is when the mistakes
begin. In November of 2024, her boyfriend reaches out to
>> God, we're going to run the timeline. Running the timeline.
Oh, I want Litterbox to be locked in for this. Okay, he's got
to be locked in. They're going to run the timeline. >> And
we have the DM because her boyfriend posted it. So, here's her
boyfriend sending him a message. It says, "Anyway, she was underage
while sending you the vast majority of that stuff. and from what
I've heard from her, you are pretty negligent about confirming
her age, even asking for ID at one point on Twitter and then
saying it was okay, just a joke. And he responded by saying,
"That's pretty weird considering that she told me she was of
age and was selling not safe for work material to people, but
okay." So, what we have here is a confirmation from Steven in
November of last year, that there was at least a possibility
that this girl was a minor, that he has images of a minor. What
happened around this time was that, including her messages with
Destiny. Now, people theorized at the time that she might be
a minor, but they didn't know for sure, which is why these, you
know, psychos online hyperfocused in on this because they're
like, I think these are a minor, and I want to try to >> Wait,
is this is this this is this a Taylor Loren's article or is it
>> okay?
If this if this is Queen Bee, if Queen Bee is in Loner's DMs
sending him all of this stuff, okay, like you just sent me all
of the the the PV, okay, I'll kill you. I will find you and I
will kill you, Queen Bee, okay? cuz I swear to God I just want
his opinion on some of this stuff to know that he's seen this
information. Okay, it's all right. All right, it's fine. >> That
someone else
who wrote this. Yeah, it's Taylor. >> I'm like so annoyed
when I can see that he's clearly looking at his DMs. I can see
now that this monitor with the dark money article is the other
side. I don't see I' I don't think I've seen him look in this
direction the entire stream. The monitor with the video on it
is this side. I do not think he's looked in this
>> Yeah.
Wow. Well, if she said it, it doesn't mention Progressive Victory,
but maybe Progressive Victory had like an overarching thing.
There's no way that this is like a separate entity that they've
overlapped with. That wouldn't be the case, would it? Wow. Okay.
>> It sounds like this chorus thing is something very very
similar to PV in some way. I've se I've heard of different things
kind of like this chorus thing. I think >> I'm sure it's
very reliable. >> I think prove it so we can nail Destiny.
So, it wasn't even like the boyfriend told him. There was already
this idea that she might have been a minor, which was the whole
reason for this hubbhub. So he knew she was maybe a minor and
he kept the footage. So from this moment at the end of last year,
he's potentially mishandling child. He at no point turned it
into the police, right? He kept it in his spank bank, right?
And by the way, one of his constant defenses is you guys are
using >> Why don't people call it a wank bank? Doesn't
make more sense than spank bank. >> I I'm sorry.
It actually is just like I'm just seeing Stardust when I when
I like watch the I was like, "Oh, Stardust reacting to my argument
with like Sunday from the other night." This is like a couple
months ago. Maybe that'll be funny. Maybe I'll get to watch her
be. It's like the same thing where it's like there's no comment
that's actually related to the content. It's essentially all
related to like side tangents and >> Where's Van? >> It's
very frustrating. Okay. >> Vos is just sailing into the
sunset. Like nothing. >> I think this is unusual. Yeah,
I don't think this is like normal for Loerbox to just not pay
attention to the content that's on the stream at all. >> Happened.
Okay. So, that seems to be the bit that was Yeah, that was the
bit that was skipped. Okay.
>> no, there's more.
>> We don't say wank. No way. I guess Americans jiz kit.
>> Yeah, but spank doesn't make any sense. You don't spank
yourself. >> He's done. It's the He's done. Like, right
within 30 seconds of this, he's done. Do we we didn't even cover
the part where uh we didn't even cover the part here where we
see that Destiny like aided in Kiwi Farms doxing rose
when you're I don't know, maybe some of you guys do [__]
weirdos.
Uh, Black Ice 32, thank you for the 11 months. Thank you very
much. Black ice 32, I'm going to thank some of the other guys.
Your buddy Ryan, thank you for the 16 months. Kio, thank you
for the 16 months. Bito, thank you for the 16month anniversary_,
thank you for gifted sub to Noah Tannon Bomb. I have any Cooking
a Pizza, thank you for the five months. And I think that's all
of our individual subs from today, guys. Thank you very much.
Appreciate all of you. Appreciate you very much. Okay, Benny,
why don't you chill the out, Benny? Why don't you chill the out?
Uh, I want to go to the the PV. Hold on. Apparently, Hassan looked
at this. Okay. Paid propagandist. >> I obviously have a
lot of >> Oh god, this is an hour. We might have to save
this until tomorrow. It's possible we save it till tomorrow.
It's possible we save it till tomorrow. Do I want to take a look
at the article? I might want to take a look at Taylor's new article
here. All right, here we go. Let's take a look cuz this is talking
about some chorus and somebody said that, oh, it's money from
Israel. Like I saw a tweet about this being money from Israel
and I don't know that it is. So, we'll see.
Why is chat so mad about loner? Uh cuz he literally just didn't
comment on any of the video that I was like interested in hearing
his commentary on. He had like actually zero engagement with
it. Zero interesting commentary.
Actually zero.
And it was like for the section I was actually interested in,
he had no interesting commentary whatsoever. And I don't even
think he could test that. He just didn't even attempt anything
interesting. So like I could look at this. When do we get to
the part where we actually see him? Yeah. So 28 minutes, he stopped
right before we actually got to the part that would have been
interesting. All right, so we're 15 seconds away from this section
where Ethan covers like Destiny actually being the person who
docks his rose >> information. He is the one that caused
this whole thing
>> where he gives the the college all of this. So like
for me, I'm like, dude, why aren't you looking at that?
Yeah. Like I don't trust me. I joked with Dickers when Dickers
came on here earlier and I wasn't I wasn't going in. I was tearing
into Loader Box and Dickers joked. I was like, "Just let me sweep
for Loader Box in peace, bro." Okay. I like want to be on Loter
Box's side, but it dude that was not that was not good commentary.
I don't even need him to, by the way, like take my side or a
disagree, but give an opinion, right? You I don't think you can
disagree without giving a opinion, but like do something. Do
something. Do something.
Get off your ass, you know?